that was the US Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo and the secretary of the Treasury
Stephen minuchin speaking in Washington
DC and what they've just announced as a
ratcheting up of sanctions on the
Iranian government a series of new
sanctions really have been announced
I'll just tell you some of what those
are the US Secretary of Treasury did
announce 17 new sanctions they target
Iran steel and iron industries he says
this is to further hamper the Iranian
economy and the secretary State Mike
Pompeo says that the newest sanctions on
Iran will also be targeting eight senior
officials that have allegedly plotted
attacks within the region and abroad
that's according to the Secretary of
State and just a reminder that the US
officials say these sanctions follow the
missile strikes that took place on US
bases in Iraq and that was as a result
of the killing of the Iranian general
Qasem Soleimani let's bring in our White
House correspondent Kimberly how
adjoining us from Washington you were
listening in this is really ratcheting
up as I'm saying
Kimberly of the sanctions on Iran
ratcheting it up and there was some
speculation here in Washington just
among the reporters here waiting for
this announcement to come down and the
question becomes is this also a
face-saving measure by the US president
who promised that if Iran struck back
against the United States for its
assassination of general Soleimani
that he would not hesitate to act but
then of course when those strikes came
we did see hesitation on the part of the
president at least militarily now we
have heard since then when he spoke to
the American public in the hours after
those strikes that he said in fact that
there would be sanctions but he gave no
specifics so this is something that we
have been waiting for Doreen and to put
this all into context I think it's
important to know for our viewers where
things stand with respect to sanctions
because this maximum pressure economic
campaign by the United States has been
in place for some time it started with
the withdrawal of the United States from
the agreement the jcpoa to limit Iran's
nuclear program that's when those
snapback sanctions that had been lifted
as a result of Iran signing that
agreement were put back in place then we
had more
sanctions put in place by the United
States last June hard-hitting sanctions
targeting Iran's supreme leader as well
as the foreign minister and then last
September targeting the central bank and
the sovereign wealth fund so it really
does now appear and we heard there from
the Treasury secretary they've attempted
to really not only isolate Iran from the
global financial system but really
[ __ ] it economically in terms of what
the US Secretary of State said there is
to punish it and take punitive action
for what the United States sees as its
destructive foreign policy and kimberley
interestingly the Secretary was stayed
in particular was questioned several
times by journalists on what he had been
saying the past couple of days about an
imminent threat from in Iran including
on US embassies that prompted the u.s.
to kill general Qasem Soleimani but he's
still not providing any evidence on what
that imminent threat is no you're
absolutely right that was another one of
the headlines to come out of that and
that is something that is certainly the
subject of headlines here in the United
States whether or not the President may
have tried to detract from the negative
impeachment headlines in the Senate
trial the impending Senate trial by
taking out general Soleimani in the form
of an assassination the White House is
denying that this was an assassination
for political purposes domestically but
certainly that is something that
continues to hover over this White House
in light of those briefings on Capitol
Hill
one more headline to come out of there
Darion very quickly as well is this
discussion and this once again confusing
message on US troop withdrawal we did
hear earlier from the iraqi prime
minister in a statement that in fact
there was a discussion with the
secretary of state and the iraqi prime
minister about putting in place a
delegation to in iraq a US delegation to
begin putting in place a mechanism for
the troop withdrawal but we've since
heard from the secretary of state there
and had a statement saying that isn't
the case that there's a real difference
of opinion on that and that any
delegation sent to iraq will be to
discuss
strategic partnerships not troop
withdrawal that the u.s. worked to
eradicate ISIL from the region is not
yet complete so once again confusing
messages coming out of this
administration not concrete's not only
on the innocent imminence of the threat
with regard to US interest and the need
to take out general Soleimani but also
the concern there about the troop
withdrawal Iraq saying that they need
that to begin the United States saying
not so fast
all right so Kimberly thank you for that
update from Washington let's find out if
there's been any reaction from Tehran on
these new sanctions dorset Jabari
joining us from there as we're saying
dorsa 17 new sanctions targeting steel
and iron industries in the country as
well as sanctions on eight senior
officials any reaction at all no the
iranian don't usually respond to these
kinds of sanctions this is becoming a
regular occurrence here weekly basis
there are new US sanctions announced on
various individuals we've had a plethora
of sanctions really over the past six
months on the country's supreme leader
the country's foreign minister now some
of the high-ranking officials alongside
those names including the head of the
boats force sorry at the head of the
passage forces rather that's the
volunteer branch of the Revolutionary
Guards as well as the Secretary of the
Supreme National Security Council Alisha
I'm Connie this is a body that deals
with the country's foreign policy as
well as the nuclear issues under the
guidance of the supreme leader
we also heard the name of Mawson reza
who is a former head of the
Revolutionary Guards he is now part of
the Expediency Council so these are very
high-ranking officials who will not be
affected by these sanctions they've
never set foot on the United States and
they don't have any interests in that
country these are more seen as a
symbolic move really on the part of the
US government what will likely happen is
that his explanation the Secretary of
State mark Pompeo is explanation our
reasoning behind the imminent so-called
threats from Jason
fossum Soleimani is yet to be really
flushed out there is really no actual
explanation that they have given the one
point to make here is that they believe
by taking out this general they've taken
out somebody who had very much influence
in this region he's very much more of an
ideology now in Iran the person
soleimani name is now associated with an
idea more than anything else and that's
something that they cannot really get
rid of the other point to make is that
the secretary of the Treasury secretary
Stephen Newton said that the previous US
administration gave a hundred billion
dollars to the Iranians when they signed
the jcpoa it's important to point out
that the Iranians got back 150 billion
dollars u.s. that was under sanctions
that was frozen assets in the United
States that was their money prior to
even the 1979 revolution so that those
funds were released when they signed the
jcpoa that is something the Obama
administration didn't simply give to the
Iranians these are important points to
highlight I think what we will see in
the coming days is an more sort of the
same kind of rhetoric from here that the
United States continues this policy of
economic terrorism on Iran after taking
out one of the highest-ranking generals
within the establishment a writer sir
Jabari thank you for that update from
Tehran